hello there fortnite's new biome has
brought with it amazing new tech new
characters and another step in
storytelling this season sees us jump
from the medieval past into the neon
streets of Tokyo inspired Mega City I'm
Adam Mario you're awesome this is the
fortnite storyline of chapter 4 season
2. at the end of last season I already
made a video breaking down the entirety
of season one I'll link that now if you
want a more in-depth view with evidence
for now let's stick to the core points
the island was remade using landmasses
from multiple time periods and realities
a guy named the Ageless rules this
island and we think he's a snapshot of
Geno the leader of the imagined order
another chap named stellen was tasked
with creating a rift gate to open a link
to other realities that gate was
sabotaged and ultimately caused this new
biome to fall from the skies above us
it's the kind of weird only fortnite can
get away with now for the new story
Mega City and the surrounding areas are
filled with Japanese influence from the
architecture to these kinetic or infused
katanas what seems picturesque from the
outside hides an imminent war that we
must prevent our season's objective is
to keep the peace after playing a video
game about hacking we are contacted by a
well-known character
hey hacker looking for a challenge well
you found it Evie has been on the island
since chapter three season two when her
faction the peace Syndicate joined the
war against the imagined order she then
stayed after the island was freed and
just vibed with us since then another
member joined twin but they both kept
their cards close to their chest until
now hi maybe I work with the peace
Syndicate and I've been working off for
the adventure you're looking for you see
that big beautiful city on your map
that's my hometown and it's in serious
trouble what are the chances of that
from all the realities possible it's
Evie's Homeworld that has arrived
whether that is coincidence or a bit of
manipulation we'll look at that another
time right now we need to meet another
member of the peace Syndicate and this
one is a lieutenant
you're the hero Evie's been telling me
about it meet Thunder a reptile Crime
Boss with culinary skills to die for
the party lizard and well-loved
after completing a few skill challenges
to prove we are recruitable we are
trusted with the real issue at hand
someone is trying to start a war between
the syndicates they know that without
Unity this city will fall apart so
another faction waiting in the wings we
shall call the chaos Syndicate
attempting to push this new place into
war by turning one Syndicate against
another the current Emma with sabotage
messing with one Syndicate and pinning
the blame on another we joined the story
as the peace Syndicate have been
targeted by that chaos group who have
hacked their key Intel and corrupted it
the peace syndicate's Data Network is
this saboteur's latest Target I need you
to re-establish our connection so off we
Trot to fix the issue and reconnect the
database and just like the best
technicians in the world we simply turn
things off and on again
so much definitely still
all in our secure service if you can
figure out what this data Thief
and why we'll be one step closer to
catching the corporate we fix it but not
completely some of the database is
permanently corrupted but the more
important stuff like Thunder's cookbook
is still here and we can also read files
on recent P Syndicate members too such
as Evie she has full clearance to the
peace Syndicate Intel which means she's
near the top of the hierarchy of this
organization oh but for some reason
she's on probation I wonder what she
could have done wrong twin who we met
last chapter is officially a field agent
currently on an assignment somewhere
stashed that really mediocre skin is a
freelance contractor for The Syndicate
who is on for a promotion soon and even
peely is on the watch list of the peace
Syndicate to become part of their team
they must have seen his heroics against
the imagined order the true hero of the
story is Bailey
sadly the rest of the data is lost
including extensive notes on the last
reality
and Oliver Intel in the army of the last
reality has been corrupted
before saboteurs working with them
by visiting Evie or thunder one last
time we are given the plan we have to
win the trust of each Syndicate one by
one we've got to unite as a city and
find The Saboteur before it's too late
you'd think that was the end of the
beginning but more is here on the island
to discover in particular this guy
[Music]
triac knocks there are two locations on
the entire map in which we can access
the peace Syndicate data using a PC that
looks like it was made in the 1980s at
each of these terminals Knox can be
spotted these terminals are most likely
where the hacker entered the database so
if we put two and two together it looks
like triac knocks is The Saboteur and
here's a really weird thing when we meet
NPCs in the world they are always
recorded in our collection book yet
triac knocks is not suspicious isn't it
and what he says doesn't help either he
doesn't want us to use the terminal I
wonder why have we really found the data
thief in week one there are many
theories about this guy right now for
example his initials are TN which are
the initials of the enemy we still know
nothing about the nothing literally the
nothing also Knox is another word for
darkness and triak is a name given to
three equal rulers of Governors there
could be two more people like him and he
talks about chaos a lot which could be
just the name of a Syndicate or it could
be a link to the Chaos Agent and how
that shapeless man will be reintroduced
to the story the potential here is
incredible but I do not want this video
to be a theory video I want to keep to
the facts as well as we know them so
let's stick a pin in triac knocks and
come back to that later we are looking
for peace right now which brings us to
the return of the fox Clan
this is one of the battle pass skins
stray he's confirmed to be a special
operations expert at the Fox Clan a
faction we first learned about in
chapter 1 when drift and everyday
Californian was brought into this world
thanks to a rift the fox Clan once again
grabbed our attention after Vai of V
however you say it hacks the fortnite
Twitter account to try and contact drift
claiming something old and bad was
hunting them down and then last season
members of the fox Clan could be seen
thanks to Rift encounters three members
would appear then quickly leave again
without warning a week later two members
would appear and then leave again
without warning and in the last week A
Lone Fox Clan member stood crying in a
field they were in trouble but we didn't
know why or from who fast forward to
this season and stray has arrived
joining drift Catalyst VI and Vox Hunter
and a few snapshots too as soon as we
get our heads around this new
information there's a new Dynamic to it
instantly according to his blurb stray
left his rightful Clan the river guard
to join their bitter Rivals the fox Clan
and to add extra to this fire his sister
is the Empress of the river Clan and
she's just found out that stray has
returned home we know very little about
the river guard right now but in just a
few weeks we'll be desperately trying to
keep the peace between those two
factions a traitorous brother will go
face to face with his Empress sister in
a future update
foreign
fortnite Mega has so much to teach us
the peace Syndicate and the fox Clan
return the chaos Syndicate and the river
Clan joined the story and the last
reality are around here somewhere and
probably Jenna too this story has more
layers than you expect I'll be sure to
keep you updated after each story update
I'm Adam you're awesome I'll be in my
DMs this week to thank people who used
my code to buy the battle pass thank you
very much for supporting me I'll see you
next time foreign
[Music]